okay gronkowski family i have to start
off by saying
i have never seen a group of men that
look so much alike
you all look exactly alike
it's like your brothers or something
this is like a big family reunion
so i'm excited to talk to you guys about
the youtube channel before we get to
that
rob obviously the question right now
that everybody is asking is just like
how close is this new gronk
to this vintage grog what would you say
oh wow wow
vintage that is crazy that's
you know that's a special word you know
vintage grunt
that sounds like i'm coming out of a
movie
but uh you know i'm just out there
working hard
just uh getting back to that football
terminology
getting getting my football legs back
underneath me because that's such a
thing too
you gotta you gotta actually compete uh
versus other uh players in order to get
the football legs back
now when i was facing my brothers in
basketball and homeroom derby
and a lot of other events it got me
ready a little bit and then when i
stepped on the field it was a little bit
different a little bit faster but
i'm just getting back at it feeling good
you know just trying to get better every
day
and uh you know i got a long camp ahead
of me so
there's a lot of football to be played
and a lot of room for improvement for
sure
now you guys tell me what can we expect
from the youtube channel i'm very
excited for this new content
well first off how i got ready for the
season this year is because i stayed
competing
it wasn't necessarily football but i was
doing everything else
from getting checked in a limo bus you
know to get me prepared for hits up the
middle
um all the way to uh shooting basketball
competing versus each other getting
paintball shot at me for my brother
while i was on a jet ski
so just put it that way imagine
paintballs you know the pain of
paintballs as you're flying across on a
jet ski
and getting hit with it got me ready for
training camp we got many
other activities too glenn chris gord
what else did we do
man you got those 72 for a big hit yeah
what about those squats you were doing
when you were y'all you're pulling
creatures
out of the middle of the ocean oh yeah
that too we
we're pulling some crazy creatures out
middle of the ocean can't tell you what
type of creatures they were
yet we're on black tip black tip you
know josh
the black tip guy out there who's been
catching these massive like founders and
stuff well we caught a lot of good stuff
out there that
it was definitely a workout like
bringing it up and you
held your core tight the whole time so
it got you stronger there so
that's what was so cool about doing all
the shooting is that it was always
activities it kept us balanced you know
you know if we didn't work out that day
we were basically working out
uh doing the activity doing the
competition so that's
how we try to incorporate it so we can
knock a few things out at one time but
also make it you know entertaining and
fun
i would love to hear how beer pong that
competition can get you ready
for some football that's some hand-eyed
coronation right there
yeah and mine that was actually water
pong for rob
everyone else was you know having a
little bit more fun you got to drain it
in the cup you got to drop it in the
bucket
we all know what's going on with that so
you know rob had to get
ready for the season so you know we gave
him an excuse to
just have some fun and uh drink some
water and get hydrated
i was playing water fog for real i think
that's why
i you know i placed pretty high i didn't
you know i'm not going to say if i won
or not which
which i didn't but um i came close
because i had water and everyone else
was getting tipsy and i was just
laughing because i knew they couldn't
see the cups properly and i could
so he was cheating you guys no is there
anything
for the channel that one of you really
wants to do
that the other ones don't yeah so we
actually did a tight roping
competition as well which i thought was
pretty cool i wanted to keep going
higher and higher on the tightrope and
everyone else was
getting too scared to try it out so
that's something maybe next time we
weren't very good at it
um don't worry are you telling all of
our secrets bro
but i mean we got some other cool stuff
competing against each other and every
single one but some fun competitions
like the beer pong and
the cooking on derby we're singing
playing some guitars and stuff like that
uh bringing in some influencers and
other celebs to have some fun with us as
well so it's gonna be a really
fun uh channel for sure for sure
so you guys are clearly like an
incredibly fun
family when i tweet search you there's
like some people that are like oh my
gosh i would love to be
gronk's brother so i'm gonna tell you
guys some other
yeah yes you're welcome i'm gonna tell
you guys
five other famous families and you guys
are gonna rank
which ones you would like to be a part
of you can collectively decide it you're
gonna talk it out amongst yourselves
as i give you the names okay will smith
and jada pinkett smith's family
the currys the hemsworths
the kardashians the carters
we can either go from the carter's being
the backstreet boy carter
no or or
beyonce and jay-z beyonce yeah
[Laughter]
i'm gonna say rob would want to be part
of the other carter
boys which one really sticks out like
that's your easy number one
number one i'd probably go with will
smith yeah me too
actually it's just well-rounded you know
that's that's just my pick
i don't know about you bros if you guys
feel the same way but that's just how i
feel
yeah i love will smith's movies too let
dan actually uh
participate since he hasn't participated
yeah i would say i would say the curries
they're
they're good people we did an interview
with them my dad and i with the parents
and they got some some good basketball
players that we could uh hang out with
in the backyard and
slam dunk on them you know i think
they'd be really fun to play three in
the bucket with
so yeah i i actually thought opposite
our basketball game we play at our house
i don't want to play three in the bucket
with them yeah that's true
everyone the final game that i play i do
this with everybody that i
interview is the game heads up these are
the categories you can choose from
hip-hop football basketball
tv movies i think we should all have to
do movies
just because football would be too easy
three
two one
uh it's where the guy locks everyone
into
uh a basement and there's a series like
one through eight
and he makes him do crazy things uh
yes yes girl movie they uh with pom-poms
and they uh
bring it on yes wow oh
um not a unicorn but
what class i don't know how to
pass on that one uh it's where you're
trapped inside a square uh
and you're freaking out not pass i never
even heard of this movie past
me wow
fast again
um it's also a song out in uh
california i think it's a tupac song
wait not straight out of compton yeah
that's not too bad but okay
um this is not a avengers movie there's
another group of guys
um fantastic four no it's um
like baseball basketball and then
the dream team pass fastpass oh
um wow max
how did you even describe the past
that one was easy about a tornado
twister yeah abraham
lincoln yes incorrect
uh it's not um
manchester united but
[Music]
manchester city no no fast pass
okay not daddy but mommy mommy dearest
uh no um father
mother i think the grug win
oh oh yeah congrats grog
i must say after sitting here and
getting to know each of you i'm so
excited to watch your videos this was so
much fun
and congrats on the launch of your
channel and thanks for joining